hey everyone this is Jeremy she a fling
at Khan Academy thanks so much for
joining our session on best practices
for using Khan Academy with ela to that
end we are very lucky to have Madeline
one of our superstar ambassadors on the
line today talk about that very topic
how she uses Khan Academy's ela content
in her own classroom and how you can use
it in our new remote learning
environment as a quick refresher if
you're new to these webinars feel free
to ask questions at any time using the
questions feature after Madeline lays
out sort of the key points she wants to
share with you about using Khan Academy
in your classroom she'll take your
questions live so share them via the
questions format and here we go
so Madeline welcome thank you so much
for joining us today absolutely thank
you so much we're super excited to have
you here and just to give folks a sense
of weird coming from tell us about your
own journey as an educator absolutely so
this is my eighth year of teaching and
I've been really lucky to have very
different teaching experiences I have
taught in two different states in five
districts I've taught in rural suburban
urban settings and I've taught middle
school and elementary currently I teach
third grade very cool and how long have
you been using Khan Academy for and what
do you typically use it for in your
classroom so I've used it for a little
over two years and I use it for a lot um
so I got started mainly using it for
math and that's how I do my math for
work actually is through Khan Academy um
but over time as I've gotten more
comfortable with it I use so much on it
now I use grammar I use the ela beta
that just came out recently I used the
computer programming and I also used
history very cool okay sounds like
you're a Khan Academy's Super User so
that's perfect that's what we need and
so for those who want to aspire for
Super User status but are just getting
started today especially in this
difficult environment we find ourselves
in any beginner tips for just getting
started with Khan Academy especially as
it pertains to ela um you know I think
that some of the the easiest ways to get
started
well if your elementary I really
recommend adding multiple courses to
your classroom so adding math grammar
and the beta ela and then just kind of
explore what those have to offer
I think the ela beta is really awesome
to be able to use as more complete units
of study and then the grammar is nice
for those little check-ins to reinforce
skills you've taught in the classroom
very cool
let's actually just pull up some of that
so folks can see it on their screen
we've just added a new class and out of
curiosity is I know it's always comes up
how do you even get your students
enrolled
I know it's especially a challenge with
elementary students yeah so if your
middle or high school I say don't enroll
them yourself share it push it out via
Google classroom it's really easy on
Khan Academy to do it that way but if
your elementary especially right now I
would just go ahead and create your
students accounts for them I know that
so many parents are overwhelmed and so
that's just one thing that you can do
all you have to do is type in the
student's name and then a username and
password will be created and then just
um it then you can just email it out to
families and it's really easy just
download the CSV for sure some people
skip that and which is really
interesting to me don't skip it download
it so that you have that on your
computer I mean you can access it other
ways but I mean that's going to be the
easiest great and so you know once
someone has created their class and
they've applied all those different
courses that you were talking about how
did you even get started like how would
you get a student using ela on Khan
Academy for the first time so um what
you're gonna want to do is first you're
gonna want to assign something so that
when the students get into Khan Academy
there is something for them to do and so
I teach third grade so I would go into
the third grade beta and then
and just click on a unit so right now
I've been doing a lot of actually the
vocabulary and because we've done so
much of that work in the classroom
I think it's nice during this time to
first start off with something you have
already covered with them in person
if this is new to them they're gonna
feel more comfortable if okay I know
what context clues are okay and then
they can they can do an assignment that
feels a little bit more familiar even if
it's a new website so that's what I
started with we've been doing so much
context clues so I find them something
on there even though my super
comfortable with it and here's an
example of what some of those questions
look like now imagine that someone is
going to start kind of coming for the
first time not having that sort of prior
experience in the classroom with it
would you recommend rolling this out
like over a zoom conversation or Google
meeting or like how would you even give
students a sense of what they're
supposed to be doing and what an
assignment looks like yeah so I would
definitely do a some sort of live
meeting and get them excited about it
explain why you're gonna be using it
maybe you want to share you know if
you're not familiar with Khan Academy
they get mastery points and they get to
create avatars for themselves and things
like that and so um if you're working
with younger kids like I am or even some
of the older kids they get excited about
that so walking them through it you know
through share screens so that they can
see what it looks like um the first time
I did Khan Academy or the first time I
do Khan Academy with my class at the
beginning of the year we always do an
assignment together and so um you can do
that in you know your live hangout you
could have each of the kids write down
the answer they think is the correct one
and pulled it up and then they were
doing it together and they're getting a
tutorial of how to use it
very cool and so when you're ready to
sort of like go to prime time and say
okay I want to make this part of my
regular classroom fabric such as our
classrooms exist today how would you
build it into your routine how would you
make it easy and regular for your
students
and so I think that depends on what your
schedule looks like right now I know
that for some teachers they are putting
an announcement every day on seesaw well
you can put a link into seesaw some
people are doing assignments through
Google classrooms some people are doing
a live check in every day so for me I'm
doing mostly live checkin check-ins
and so at the end of my time I remind
them okay now it's the time that you're
gonna get onto Khan Academy I want you
to do the assignment that's named
such-and-such um and so just building it
in that way would be what I would
suggest very cool I'll just mention that
every piece of content on Khan Academy
has a unique URL so if you ever just
didn't either paste a link to a video or
to a specific exercise you can do that
right into a seesaw or a learning
management system in addition to the
assignment process that works like this
as far as the reporting goes I know
we're in a very different environment
right now but how much are you looking
at those reports are you translating it
into grades as a matter so I am not
doing great um that's not an expectation
at the elementary level however I am
still using those reports so one of the
things that I see as fantastic about
Khan Academy is there are great videos
that are tutorials right for the
students to use so I don't have to spend
my time doing that there's great lessons
I don't have to spend my time doing that
instead I can use my time looking at
those reports and so just a quick story
of what happened today I assigned two
math assignments and I was looking at
the scores from students one of my top
maths and kid I was scored poorly and so
then I was able to look at a different
report which shows student activity so
then it shows me how long students have
spent not just navigating the pages but
actually on the assignments and he had
spent six minutes on two assignments
which is just not enough
for that type of assignments that I had
uploaded and so because I had this extra
time I was able to check in with that
family and I would I just said you know
hey how did the assignments go oh it
turns out their Wi-Fi was in and out and
he was really stressed about that and
tried to get both assignments in before
the Wi-Fi went out again and so I
wouldn't have known that if I didn't
have those reports to look back on I
could have just been like oh this was a
tough skill for him and moved on but
instead I got to build that relationship
and talk to him about oh you know it's
totally fine if you have to wait until
later to get it done that's fine there's
no um you know stress to get this done
right away very cool so I love how you
close the feedback loop they're like I
feel like as teachers in our normal
classrooms we're constantly having that
feedback loop all day every day where a
student does some work we're giving them
a response they're getting that needed
feedback versus that's so hard in this
sort of remote learning environment but
you're still closing that loop using
Khan Academy to generate the data yeah
super really good so the questions are
starting to pour in okay so if you're
good Madelyn I love to bring up a
question from Don and herb and Kelly
which is what does an ela beta what does
that even mean how can we be thinking
about that so it's basically um Khan
Academy and you can talk to this
probably much better but um they are
adding English language arts as part of
their lessons and they're just in beta
right now so that means that they're
testing them out they're seeing what's
working well what's not getting feedback
from people so that they can improve
them well time but so right now there's
multiple topics that you can choose from
so there's reading passages there are
there's um nonfiction and and fiction
and then
there's also just specific skills like I
talked about with the vocabulary like
and using glossary some dictionaries and
things like that so it I'm super excited
about it cool and just share the link
with everyone if you're gonna use it and
give us feedback please just use that
link to let us know because our content
developers are really eager for that
kind of information
speaking of feedback loops let's see
here so woo okay
so Ramona says I'm a fifth grade ela and
social studies teacher looking for ways
to integrate Khan Academy it's my remote
learning construction I already have my
students working through Google
classroom are there any special tips you
would offer for Google classroom users
given they use it awesome so I use
Google classroom too and there's a lot
of compatibility between Khan Academy
and Google classroom which is fantastic
and you can actually in your Khan
Academy account even sync your Google
classroom to your to your Khan Academy
class and yeah perfect and then explain
a little bit more about what is thinking
look like where did that actually do for
the teacher or for the students so then
it just makes it um well I wish that I
could oh yeah
I don't you have to share your screen
cuz I know you got your students
personal information out there we bet
our fabricated data here yeah so um then
it just shares the information yeah yeah
I think I'm the easiest way to explain
it is like if you've already done the
hard work of getting students on in
Google classroom and everyone is all set
up there if you have to add a student or
changes student Google classroom those
changes are automatically populated in
your Khan Academy class so that way you
have to double work because it's all
being fed over and I know there's been a
lot of concern about like too much
information going out to families and so
this is a way that you can cut down on
that and there's less for the students
to click what about a really juicy
question for you from Kathleen I love
this question I know that it's very
tempting in the middle of this crisis to
be totally focused on just getting
through the day I was turning that way
most days but if we're already thinking
about next year and setting our students
up for success if a student starts Khan
Academy this year will their data go
with them to their next year's teacher
so they could benefit from understanding
what they've done so far oh that's an
awesome question um if well it depends
on um hopefully your students are
signing up with their um school email
and or or just using the same login then
it my understanding is that it should um
I haven't followed the same group of
students and I was teaching at an older
grade but from what my students have
told me it follows them what do you have
more on that absolutely now you nailed
it so basically as long as they're
logging in with their school account and
that school account stays the same
they'll carry all all that good
information with them and future
teachers can benefit um lots of
questions from high school educators
like Nancy and Jennifer say hey I love
all this stuff for third
eighth grade ela what about us high
school teachers would you recommend that
the vocabulary and grammar lessons are
relevant for those students as well I
think it really depends on the students
I mean you are the experts on your
students you're gonna know that the best
I've used the grammar with middle school
and I'm sure high school teachers you
would agree that there are some holes in
grammar and so I would certainly and I
would certainly use it for high school
and what you might just want to change
what that looks like and you might want
to
well there's unit tests for each and
each thing so like if we go to sentence
and clauses or if we go to nouns and
there's gonna be a unit test so it might
just look different where you will find
that at the beginning and see how they
do on that and then figure out what
individual skills you want to go over
instead of finding every single
assignment I love that actually you
echoed exactly what Tim Vandenberg your
fellow ambassador had shared a couple
weeks ago which is even for a sixth
graders he has them go back and actually
master each of these things is that they
forget they didn't learn about nouns in
first grade if they didn't learn about
adverbs in third grade he can actually
fill in those gaps and make sure they're
ready for sixth-grade work or even ninth
grade work yep
okay let's see here
okay here's an important question I
think that's really speaks probably to
the Elementary population that you're
most familiar with Marta wants to know
if I've already created the students
usernames and passwords be the process
that you just outlined what should I
send to the parents and the students
themselves should I just send them that
information directly or is there any
preferred way to go about that
communication um so I've never had to do
it with distance learning um so that's a
great question um what I would do is I
mean again each school looks different
right now we're having to send out a
weekly email to parents and so you could
input it within that and then so that's
probably what I would
is just a screenshot the user in each
individual username and you could do
that Oh perfect yeah I was gonna add I
think you're absolutely right totally
the best way to do it whatever is
natural for your sort of communication
style if using seesaw or screen capture
tools Khan Academy does have I'm a
formal letter to parents where you can
list it that's in a bunch of different
languages which I'll share in the chat
here and you can always take advantage
of these if you just need some language
to get started with but I think that
your your point is totally valid
Madeline okay hopefully they get you
started Marta I know it's a tough tough
thing to do midstream especially given
that the stream we're wading in right
now is very deep ooh here's a really
interesting question they're gonna
challenge you a little bit but Shelly
who's actually working with students
that are focused on GED wants to know if
there are parts of Khan Academy they're
actually even appropriate for
self-directed learning so that's about
assignment assignment assignment more
about I'm empowered to go forth and
learn as a student yeah actually I think
that something that the more comfortable
you can get any student with Khan
Academy the more that will naturally
happen it means for an older learner
it's gonna happen very naturally it can
definitely be self-paced some of my
third graders in the time that they were
waiting for me to get up and running
with online education assigned to
themselves computer programming and
biology and started going through those
lessons and so absolutely this would be
great for self-paced instruction very
cool and just to make that really really
sort of lucid you know any single user
of Khan Academy whether you're a teacher
or a student can always click this
courses button in the upper left hand
corner and really can start digging in
on whatever they're curious about so if
you do have adult learners or older
learners we're just ready to just
dominate grammar or whatever it is that
they need to learn they can get started
even without assignments always
available to you okay great questions
Shelly great response Madelyn woo here's
a tough one so Christmas says when
sending us up for an autistic eighth
grade girl
what do you think is the best approach
and if the student had ADHD would you
think about it differently in terms of
engagement so basically just thinking
about all your different kinds of
learners I need advice for making sure
that they're all served really well
using a tool like Khan Academy mm-hmm so
again it's going to depend on your
individual student and what works best
for them so for one of my students who
has autism she actually really prefers
the videos on Khan Academy to anything
else the youth that the the use of color
is really calming to her and she loves
it and so when I posted a video of my
online instruction she her mom emailed
me and said is there actually a Khan
Academy version so for her it worked
really well and so much better for
another one of my student this year that
has autism he does not like the Khan
Academy videos but he loves the activity
and doing the assignment on there he
just prefers getting the instruction
from me so there's gonna be you know
give-and-take and I'm just I guess
having that conversation with them about
what's working with this and what's not
and you know teachers were really
flexible so just keeping that
flexibility with this as well very cool
great feedback actually very similar
saves are wants to know do you have any
students who are English language
learners and if so how do you address
that given that so much of this is
text-based mm-hmm so um I do have I do
have some students that are English
language learners so you can actually
turn on captions and though um I I will
do that with the videos because
sometimes they'll miss something or you
know they will think that two words of
the one and so it just helps with
clarity um so far it it has not been a
huge issue for my students to navigate
it but there have been times where with
some of the ELA I've been moving down to
some second grade not because they
aren't able to do the academics but I
can't put the same supports in with this
distance learning or at least I haven't
figured out a perfect way to do that yet
and so there are some times where I
might use just a little bit simpler
level so that they can access it easier
great advice balland that actually sort
of leads to a bigger question can you
speak to the the idea of differentiation
on Khan Academy grow more broadly you
know when we did our initial demo we're
mostly talking about lockstep everyone
gets the same assignment if you want to
serve each student where they are how
would you go about doing that there's so
many different ways to do that um and it
might even actually be easier for you
because you've been working with your
students in person up to this point so
you probably have a pretty good idea of
where they're at so you kind of find
from there if you don't if it's a if
it's a new concept then you can see how
they're doing on the assignments and
then you can scale back there's actually
um if you're doing math there's very
clear cut like if you need remediation
in third grade click here if you need
you know supports for this click here
and then with ela it's not there yet but
because it's in beta but you can just
yourself look through the different
levels and you can make it more
challenging for your students that need
that I find them a fourth grade or a
fifth grade or you know go the other way
cool and just to sort of operationalize
that anywhere you can make assignments
on the site whether it's on the lesson
itself or in the teacher classroom you
always have the chance to do all
students or just some of the students
and so you can really make sure that
every student is getting what they need
not just whatever the class is getting
um speaking of getting what you need
Nathan a parent actually asks really an
important question which is okay I'm a
parent of a second grade
and I'm trying to make sure that my
daughter has what she needs to get ready
for third grade but I don't want to just
like skip to third grade and start her
on that ela beta do you recommend
anything to get started at that second
grade level
um well so I would suggest doing some of
the grammar lesson that would be really
really good there's some pretty basic
things in there like nouns singular
nouns things like that so I would do
that I would think and then but I don't
think there's any harm with doing what
beta is available for second grade and
filling the time at that for now yeah
have you ever um used Khan kids with
your students at all
battlin well yeah my students but I have
two little little ones Oh with my
three-year-old he is this Khan Academy
and you know he's not going to preschool
anymore which was pretty devastating for
him and so he uses Khan Academy kid and
um he he loves it and he was really
excited because that is continuing to
develop and so recently there was
assignments for a first grade that came
up and he was so excited about new
videos and so it's a great tool um it's
an app that um it'll go through short
lessons and you can either select the
lessons yourself or you can just press
play and it will lead you through
lessons absolutely it's all free all
available on these the app stores as you
can see on the screen and in some ways
that's easy to get started with
especially in this remote learning
environment because like you said
Mallory you just started and just go
it's you know have to worry about these
assignments and everything else so it
could be a nice way for the early
elementary educators out there to get
their students started and you can still
report right right
Oh Mouse Sara from Guilford County North
Carolina asked and this is a very
important question can you actually
preview the lesson in videos before you
assign them or you basically just
sitting in a dark and hoping for the
best no you can absolutely preview
anything I do the assignment myself now
there's um sometimes with some of the
assignments there's lots of different
possible questions that could be asked
and I'll just run through one
possibility but just so I have a good
idea of what what I'm actually asking
students to do so yes you can preview
everything which is really nice you can
preview oh because you can the students
when they're doing the assignment can
have access to hints and so I like to
see what those are going to look like
for the student very cool and a little
pro tip just to go along with that is if
you're ever curious what your students
are experiencing I'm sure you are
add yourself as a students your own
classroom and that way you actually have
the ability to see every email every
notification everything your students
are about to get now all you have to do
is come in here to your classroom
dashboard go to the class code so over
he's in the upper right hand corner and
then under your name go to learner home
and from there you can actually add
yourself as a student and see everything
with the students ease through their
eyes have you ever done that Madeline
has ever okay cool also I just add
courses that I'm interested in so like I
think I have astronomy in there right
now and I show the kids like hey this is
something I'm excited about I'm gonna be
learning and so then they kind of feel
like oh you're using us too
you're a learner too and kind of build
that connection too
I love that I need tips speaking of that
about just like growth mindset
especially in this moment when we feel
like so deflated and we're like I don't
even want to you know think about
tomorrow how do you keep your students
feeling really strong and persistent
right now um that's a good question we
you know just keeping things light at
the beginning of each academic year I do
growth mindset lessons with them through
Khan Academy um that's of course that
they have available that
nice to help kids get into that mindset
but I think just continuing the
connection with your kids is so
important in whatever week pretty cool
and then two final questions for you
number one where do you typically go to
get support if you run into challenges
with Khan Academy or just want to learn
from other educators so there's some
Facebook groups for Khan Academy
educators and that's really nice because
you get feedback really quickly you can
just type in your question like hey
who's run into this or hey you know I'm
running into this issue how have you
motivated students and you get responses
really quickly so I highly recommend
joining that it is a private group so
just have to ask ask for access very
cool and then lastly you know as we face
the tough tough month ahead of us and
maybe even a little more any words of
wisdom that you want to share with Ala
educators out there just as far as how
to stay strong in this moment and how to
serve their students the best way
possible I think take a deep breath and
less is more you're doing the best that
you can for your students just by being
there and by trying and it's just gonna
be a steep learning curve so try to have
as much fun with it as you can cool I
think those are great words to end on so
Madeleine thank you so much for being
with us today
away from your own children your own
students serve other educators and thank
you all for joining us and we wish you
well on your journey in the next couple
months ahead absolutely have a great
deal